[Música]
para mons
hola a todos soy raymond y quiero
hablaros de un elemento que todo el
mundo conoce pero quizá sea un gran
desconocido el cubo de rubik yo supongo
que todos lo conocemos no quién tiene un
cubo de rubik en su casa que levante la
mano vale veo que bastante gente baja la
mano y quién sabe resolverlo
eso ya es más complicado nos algunos la
levanta tímidamente pues pocos son los
elegidos capaces de resolver los cubos
de rubik todo empezó en el año 1974
su inventor es ernö rubik fijaos qué
nombre tan raro y es que es húngaro él
era profesor de arquitectura y escultor
y él cuando inventó el cubo de rubik no
pretendía hacer un puzzle sabéis que
quería hacer pues una escultura una
pieza de arquitectura en la que bueno
giran sus piezas sin descomponerse en el
cubo mantenía su integridad lo que
arquitectónicamente es curioso y el
mismo que es este de aquí ernö rubik
perdón y ernö rubik el mismo al poner
una cara de cada color se dio cuenta que
había creado un puzzle
y él tardó un mes en resolverlo no sabía
lo que había creado el tío y también
aquí está la foto del prototipo no así
una escultura pues con sus decoraciones
de madera y bueno yo aprendí a
resolverlo por un tutorial de youtube
al final en una tarde o dos lo aprendes
pero al principio ha tardado un poco de
tiempo pero fui bajando mi marca hasta
22 segundos que es mi récord actual es
poco no no está mal pero teniendo en
cuenta que el récord mundial ahora mismo
es 4 segundos con 69 o así lo mío es una
eternidad aunque yo estoy satisfecho
tampoco pretendo bajar de ahí y claro lo
aprendí en un tutorial de youtube cosa
que en los años 80 al principio no había
no entonces tiene más mérito saberlo
resolver y rápido la primera competición
de velocidad fue en el 82 y el primer
récord mundial fue 22 segundos con 95
y mi récord es 22 claramente me
equivocado de época podría tener un
récord mundial perfectamente pero una
vez que lo aprendes a resolver que no
pues bueno es un mundo
muy amplio muy amplio y bueno esto es un
estado del cubo de rubik y una
combinación el estado resuelto este es
el segundo por ejemplo así 345 hay
muchos no cuantos hay de cuántas maneras
se puede poner un cubo de rubik pues
agarrados al asiento porque las cifras
va a dejar anonadados fijaos
bueno este es el aspecto del primer cubo
de rubik muy ochentero
y la cifra es la siguiente cuarenta y
tres trillones 252 mil tres millones
doscientos mil suficientes mil millones
un montón es el infinito encerrado en un
cubo no es imposible entender estas
cifras pero bueno una vez que aprendes a
resolverlo como decía que cuesta
cronometrar bajas de tiempo y tal pero
ya está no hay más tipos de cubos de
rubik de hecho yo los colecciono y tengo
unos 200 cubos de rubik y todos los que
resolver claro se lo que estáis pensando
este chico come duerme tiene amigos para
el tiempo para todos
pero yo creo que hay tantos cubos de
rubik como uno para cada uno fijaos lo
que digo y es que os acordáis del
anuncio de coca-cola para todos ese tan
famoso pues he creado para vosotros mi
propia versión con cubos de rubik para
todos
para los clásicos para grandes pequeños
para los altos para los bajos para los
tramposos sin pegatinas que quitar para
los niños para los ingenieros para los
arquitectos para los decoradores
para los informáticos para los
matemáticos para los ahorradores para
los derrochadores
para los que andan faltos de memoria
para la gente retorcida
para la gente muy retorcida
para la gente sencilla
[Música]
para los egipcios para los que suben
para los que bajan para los que vienen
para los que se van de compras
para los que no tienen tiempo para los
que si tienen tiempo para los que tienen
mucho tiempo
para los que viven en una isla desierta
directamente para los jugadores para los
cerebritos para los frikis
para los que están a dieta
para los que no están a dieta
para los pelotas de la clase para la
gente sincera y transparente
para los que tienen sed para los que
tienen hambre
para los que están resfriados para la
gente estresada para la gente elegante
para las parejas
para todo el mundo hay cubos de rubik
para todos
y es que es un mundo fascinante y además
al principio cuando salió al mercado su
nombre no era el cubo de rubik sabéis
durante poco tiempo se llamó el cubo
mágico
esto es verdad y a mí este tema me
encanta no que coincida porque yo ahora
tengo 23 años y bueno soy mago me dedico
a la magia y esto me gusta desde que soy
pequeño porque mis padres son magos
también y tienen son directores de una
sala de magia en madrid que se llama la
cripta mágica hace 30 años que la
abrieron o sea que yo llegué eso ya
estaba ahí y me han enseñado a amar este
arte que es la magia
y que como cualquier otra profesión pues
necesitan muchas horas para hacerse bien
pensar ser creativo leer muchos libros y
mucho mucho ensayo yo desde que me
levanto hasta que me acuesto estoy
pensando en magia y cada vez que salgo a
la calle llevo algo para hacer si
alguien me pidiera hacer magia y dijera
no es que no estoy preparado pues
estaría mintiendo nunca sabes cuando
necesitas sorprender a alguien
y es que esto se ha convertido en mi
modo de vida la magia eso no quiere
decir que los platos en mi casa se
frieguen solos o diga me voy con mis
amigos bombas de humo pues no ojalá pero
no a lo que me refiero es que es un
privilegio poderse dedicar a lo que a
uno le gusta y eso se consigue con
pasión por lo que amas
mi padre conoció a un gran mago llamado
josé sevilla de nombre artístico frac
son él fue mundialmente conocido y era
español muy importante en los años 50 su
especialidad de la magia con cigarrillos
pero él antes de salir a escena siempre
pensaba para sí mismo amo a este público
y no les conocía de nada y pensaba esto
que voy a hacer lo voy a hacer por ellos
para que lo disfruten con cariño y el
resultado era muy positivo era efectivo
no yo cada día lo aplico a mi magia y la
verdad es que es lo que me sale también
no funciona y yo hoy traigo algo de
magia para haceros y espero que ese
cariño se refleje y que lo podáis
disfrutar además con qué voy a hacer
magia
por supuesto con un cubo de rubik este
es el método convencional que es girar
sus capas para resolverlo
pero yo lo que hago en vez de girar sus
capas en vez de con habilidad
lo que hago es acariciarlo porque es muy
cariñoso este curso es así que fijaos
porque aunque está mezclado lo voy a ir
acariciando es dar la sensación de que
el cubo lentamente como que se va
resolviendo como que sus colores vuelven
a su ser hasta llegar a un punto mira se
resuelve
[Aplausos]
pero este cubo tiene más facetas es
acróbata y sabe realizar un salto
acrobático querés verlo
mira desde ahí el hombre de rojo
si estás así mira voy a ir mezclando tú
cuando quieras me dices alto yo te diré
gracias
no me paras donde quieras
aquí bien así como tú me has dejado de
intentar resolverlo con magia en nada
más que tres segundos lanzando al aire y
por detrás de mi espalda
todo eso luego intentaré porque ese hijo
así como tú me has dejado a la de tres
contamos todos fuertes 1 2
conseguido
[Aplausos]
pero podéis pensar este cubo no tiene
pegatinas sino pantallitas que se
manejan con un mando a distancia como
las diapositivas o raíles por los que se
mueven las pegatinas es un cubo
eléctrico no el eléctrico sueño mira qué
pelos por favor el nombre de rojo te
importaría ayudarme no claro que no un
fuerte aplauso para el que viene al
escenario
[Aplausos]
fantástico vamos a demostrar que el cubo
de rubik a pesar de algunos tener uno en
su casa es desconocido y tiene
cualidades mágicas vamos a demostrarlo
hoy aquí acércate cómo te llamas
carlos encantado gracias por venir bueno
te va a pedir que mezcle es el cubo
porque es muy importante que tú seas el
mezclador oficial porque adelante soy
muy torpe dice no te preocupes es carlos
bueno yo tengo aquí más cubos de rubik
aunque esté normal también un tres por
tres meramente aquí conmigo carlos ponte
por aquí esto está mezclado ya verdad
déjamelo en mientras mezclas el otro
porque esto es muy importante que todos
lo mezcles hay una bolsa y que es
transparente y ahora la vamos a utilizar
mezcla este también un poquito
fantástico y esta bolsa aunque se ve que
no tiene nada examina la todo
completamente examinada eso es
fantástico y tengo aquí un pedestal para
apoyar un poco muy bien carlos por favor
te voy a pedir que pongas el dedo en
alto aquí así y acércate al cubo hasta
tocar una cara la que quieras
bien puedes quitar el dedo esta es la
cara elegida por carlos la ponemos
mirando hacia el público y yo voy a
el otro 3 x 3 mira al monte para
ella porque lo que va a ocurrir es
mágico vamos allá
ambos cubos han sido mezclados por él
sin embargo elegiste una cara y vamos a
comprobar si esa cara coincide
a la perfección
pero un momento porque el rubí que es
tan mágico que no sólo coincide una cara
sino dos caras incluso tres caras hasta
cuatro llegamos a cinco ya podéis
aplaudir porque coinciden todo el juego
entero
[Aplausos]
un director prueba que mira que no tiene
nada es impresionante pero sabéis hay
una versión del 3 por 3 que a mí
personalmente me encanta y es esta de
aquí está un rubik de bolsillo es una
versión pequeña pero también tiene
derecho a ser resuelto digo yo
así que lo intenta resolver carlos
toques aquí cerca podrás ver que es
pequeño que sus piezas son las capas muy
finas es incómodo en las manos así que
no lo voy a hacer con las manos sino con
ayuda de la magia con la boca
sí amigos sí con la boca como se llame
[Música]
[Aplausos]
no
conseguido
gracias pero podéis pensar raymond
tienes algo escondido en la boca
carlos el cubo tiene algo extraño algo
trucado no quiero que penséis eso así
que por favor con tus propias manos
vas a comprobar que es un cubo
completamente normal si te da asco estoy
vacunado y lo prometo no tengo la
cartilla y todo nada comprobar que es un
cubo normal que gira porque sabéis el
cubo de rubik es difícil de resolver
sobre todo el de la isla desierta que
veríamos antes sin embargo este no éste
está chupón
literalmente además
mira carlos nos acercamos al final te
voy a pedir que te sitúes aquí en el
centro de firme hay algunas cosas en el
interior de esta bolsa
no además de aire el transparente no
pero de nuevo mete la mano un segundo
para ver que no tiene nada extra
con las manos en cuenco así mirando
hacia mí y lleva aquí desde el principio
un rubin mezclado por el en el pedestal
vamos a introducirlo en la bolsa y
fijaos porque cada tu te contara que
tenés que hacer con las manos por favor
abraza lo así de esta manera abrazarlo
junto a los dedos ahí quieto y no te
muevas y es fantástico pero no puedo
tocar el cubo mezclado por él pero voy a
intentar resolverlo con magia si esto
funciona damas y caballeros es el final
ahora bien si no funciona
es el final también
no te muevas carlos
[Música]
tampoco fuertísimo las bolsas más caros
muchísimas gracias muchas gracias amigos
nos vemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y